[Música]
en China avanzan las protestas contra la
política de cero covic la ONU pide a las
autoridades que respeten el derecho a la
manifestación pacífica mientras el
Ministerio de exteriores del gigante
asiático asegura no estar informado de
las movilizaciones
Moscú niega que las tropas rusas vayan a
abandonar la central nuclear de
saborilla contradiciendo así
informaciones difundidas por kiev por
otro lado las autoridades ucranianas
anunciaron que el suministro energético
está restablecido en gran parte del
territorio tras Reparar los daños en la
red causados por los bombardeos
en Estados Unidos Eric python
supremacista blanco confeso Se declaró
culpable del tiroteo racista de Búfalo
del mes de mayo en que mató a 10
personas afrodescendientes el hombre de
19 años se enfrenta cargos por ataque
terrorista motivado por el odio y podría
pasar su vida en prisión
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de Franz 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
mateu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
empezamos esta edición en China porque
este fin de semana en ciudades como
Beijing o Shanghai tuvieron lugar Las
mayores protestas en años decenas de
personas manifestaron contra la política
de Cero covid en movilizaciones que han
continuado este lunes en Hong Kong la
policía detuvo un número desconocido de
participantes de esta inédita
contestación que estalló a raíz de la
muerte de 10 personas este jueves en un
incendio en Shin Chan del que
supuestamente no pudieron escapar debido
a los confinamientos en las marchas de
este fin de semana Se oyeron consignas
que van desde demandas de más libertad
de expresión hasta la renuncia del
presidente Chip y un grito unánime el
fin de la restricciones que empezaron
hace casi tres años Luis Muñoz con las
reacciones internacionales
extrañas protestas contra los
confinamientos en Beijing
Shanghai
[Aplausos]
o Hong Kong esto en China mientras en el
mundo las manifestaciones se extienden
al frente de las embajadas como en
Londres capital de Reino Unido y Tokio
capital de Japón pero más allá del
malestar los efectos son notables los
principales índices de Wall Street
abrieron a la baja el lunes y la
comunidad internacional empieza a
pronunciarse al respecto así habló el
canciller de Reino Unido bueno las
protestas contra el gobierno chino son
raras y cuando suceden creo que el mundo
debería Tomar nota pero sobre todo es el
gobierno chino el que debería Tomar nota
de forma similar se expresó el gobierno
alemán
hemos tomado nota de las noticias de
protestas en varias de las principales
ciudades chinas también de los informes
de acciones a veces violentas de las
fuerzas de seguridad contra los
manifestantes sobre el terreno
puedo decirles que por supuesto nuestra
embajada en Beijing así como nuestras
otras misiones diplomáticas en China
continúan observando la situación de
cerca la pasada semana a un incendio en
un edificio de urumkie capital de
shinyang causó 10 muertos los
manifestantes argumentaron que las
graves restricciones que impidieron a
los fallecidos escapar y su rechazo se
ha convertido en un clamor cada vez
mayor contra casi tres años de
confinamientos aún así el país continúa
con su política de cero covid
noticias de la guerra en Ucrania el
kremlin niega que las tropas rusas estén
preparando su salida de la central
nuclear de zaporilla El portavoz del
gobierno ruso dimitrip Scott rechazó así
la información difundida por la agencia
nuclear ucraniana este domingo que
declaró tener indicios de que las
fuerzas rusas abandonarían la central
recordemos que la mayor planta nuclear
de Europa está bajo control ruso desde
el principio de la invasión y de hecho
ha sido escenario de combates que han
puesto en alerta a la comunidad
internacional una reciente emisión de la
organización Internacional de la energía
atómica constató la seguridad en la
planta Aunque el jefe de la agencia
advirtió que se está jugando con fuego
en otras noticias de la guerra este
lunes el presidente de Ucrania
fuelodimirselensky recibió en kiev a los
ministros de relaciones exteriores de
los países bálticos y nórdicos con los
representantes de Estonia letonia
lituania Islandia Finlandia Noruega y
Suecia selensky abordó las implicaciones
de la invasión rusa un encuentro de
apoyo a Ucrania en la antesala de la
Cumbre de la otan que empieza mañana
martes en bucarest los países que se
reunieron hoy con celenski forman parte
de la alianza militar excepto por Suecia
y Finlandia que sin embargo están en
proceso de integrarla
y por otro lado las autoridades
ucranianas han restablecido el
suministro energético en gran parte del
país tras los ataques rusos de esta
semana en regiones como gerson los
ciudadanos vuelven a tener acceso al gas
y a la electricidad Eso sí en medio de
la devastación causada por los
bombardeos y de las advertencias de que
los ataques podrían repetirse Alba
Santana nos amplía
tras día sin gas ni electricidad el
ludmila antonenco y su hijo Alexander
vuelven a tener acceso a estos servicios
en su casa de que son tenemos gas
tenemos electricidad Ojalá tuviéramos
agua también para usar el baño
adecuadamente el 24 de noviembre una
bomba supuestamente rusa cayó sobre su
casa las ventanas saltaron por los aires
y una de las paredes colapsó ahora a
pesar de que la casa está en ruinas
madre e hijo siguen aquí porque no
tienen otro sitio donde ir
la ventana se llenó de luz todo se
iluminó luego hubo muchas explosiones
estábamos muy asustados Me alegro de que
Alexander siga aquí si hubiera caído
Entre 10 y 30 centímetros más hacia aquí
yo no estaría aquí pero tengo 82 años no
es para tanto
otros no tuvieron tanta suerte como
Lilia krishenko que perdió a sus dos
padres en ese mismo ataque
había mucho polvo no podía ver nada mi
hijo y yo nos escondimos en el baño hoy
a mi padre gritar diciéndome que llamara
una ambulancia porque mi madre estaba
herida pero no había conexión
a pesar de que el gas y la electricidad
en los dos servicios más importantes de
cara al infierno se han restablecido los
ciudadanos de gerson no tienen acceso al
agua ni a otras redes como la de la
televisión además el presidente bolo de
mercelenski ha advertido a los
ucranianos que todavía no están a salvo
sabemos que los terroristas están
planeando nuevos ataques lo sabemos con
certeza y mientras tengan misiles
desafortunadamente no se calmarán
una situación complicada de cara al
invierno cada vez más cerca y para el
que los ucranianos sumidos en la guerra
no están preparados
en Italia continúan las tareas de
rescate tras el violento deslizamiento
de tierra en la turística isla de isquia
de este sábado los equipos de emergencia
buscan a cuatro desaparecidos mientras
se elevó a 8 el número de víctimas
mortales entre ellas se cuenta un recién
nacido expertos y activistas aseguran
que la construcción de edificios
ilegales aumentó los riesgos de
desastres naturales en esta zona insular
próxima al mar de la ciudad de Nápoles
más detalles en el siguiente informe
como si la colina se rompiera en pedazos
en pocas horas el lodo se adentró
cientos de metros en el mar Arrasando
todo a su paso Los buzos estuvieron
peinando las aguas de la costa italiana
de isquia con la ayuda de helicópteros
aquí es donde se encontró la primera
víctima una mujer de 31 años que
trabajaba en una tienda local hallada
muerta a cientos de metros de su casa
los bomberos están turnando para buscar
en la zona tratando de encontrar a los
desaparecidos pero la tarea sigue siendo
difícil en paralelo el gobierno decretó
el estado de emergencia lo que hace que
sea complejo es que nos encontramos bajo
la zona debilitada por el
desprendimiento las casas están llenas
de barro por lo que es muy complicado
Acceder al interior y continuar nuestra
búsqueda
alrededor de 200 personas fueron
desalojadas algunas se refugiaron en
este hotel cerca del puerto esta mujer
refugiada con su hijo y su nieta se
enteró de que su cuñada fue encontrada
muerta bajo los escombros
estamos tristes mantuve la esperanza
hasta el final otra tragedia en esta
ciudad y en esta familia no sé cómo voy
a afrontar los próximos días
[Música]
esta familia Tuvo más suerte su casa
sigue en pie a pocos metros de la
trayectoria de la luz
ves nuestra casa aquí pasó por allí y es
que recibió casi 13 centímetros de
lluvia en seis horas la mayor
precipitación en 20 años Este alud es el
tercer desastre natural que golpea la
isla ya víctima de un terremoto en 2017
y de mortales inundaciones en 2019
y en Estados Unidos Eric python quien se
define como supremacista blanco Se
declaró culpable del tiroteo racista de
Búfalo del mes de mayo el hombre de 19
años mató a 10 personas afro
estadounidenses con un rifle
semiautomático python enfrenta múltiples
cargos incluido el de terrorismo
doméstico motivado por el odio y puede
ser condenado a cadena perpetua
recordemos que el hombre planeó El
Atentado durante semanas lo retransmitió
en vivo por redes sociales y eligió el
escenario de la masacre por ser un
barrio de población afroe estadounidense
escuchemos al abogado de la defensa
nuestro cliente se declaró culpable de
todos los cargos de la acusación con
pleno conocimiento de que pasará al
resto de su vida en prisión sin
posibilidad de libertad condicional
Aunque el caso Federal continúa sus
acciones hoy aseguran que no habrá
ningún juicio en La Corte y no apelará
este paso representa una condena la
ideología racista que alimentó sus
horribles acciones del 14 de mayo
sigan con nosotros
[Música]